[Musik]
forschung die hoffnung macht das mainzer
unternehmen bayern tag meldet bei seinem
corona impfstoff eine wirksamkeit von
mehr als 90% vorbereitungen zur
amtsübernahme der künftige us-präsident
beiden stellt ein crooner expertenteam
vor und empörung über eskalation in
leipzig nach der querdenker demo wächst
die kritik an behörden und justiz
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann ein simulator
von mir aus mainz und new york kam heute
die nachricht die viele elektrisiert und
die börsen befeuert ein impfstoff gegen
korona könnte gefunden sein
nach firmenangaben hat er eine
wirksamkeit von mehr als 90 verursacht
keine schweren nebenwirkungen und könnte
anfang nächsten jahres auf den markt
kommen
entwickelt hat ihn die mainzer firma
biotec zusammen mit ihrem amerikanischen
partner dem pharmakonzern pfizer
die mainzer hatten schon mitte januar zu
forschen begonnen als das ausmass der
pandemie noch nicht abzusehen war ende
juli startete die entscheidende
testphase susanne gehen hat die hoffnung
auf einen wirksamen impfstoff gegen
korona wächst bisher seien die
testergebnisse vielversprechend heißt es
immer hinter unternehmen bei montech
sogar besser als erwartet man kann das
zusammenfassen das ergebnis dass der
impfstoff nach der zwischenauswertung in
der lage ist damit über 30 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit einer infektion zu
verhindern
und so wirkt der sogenannte m rna
impfstoff über ein boten molekül werden
genetische informationen des corona
virus in den menschlichen körper
gebracht der körper stellt damit virus
proteine her gegen die das immunsystem
abwehrstoffe bildet der impfschutz
beginnt in der entscheidenden phase 3
der klinischen tests wurden seit ende
juli mehr als 43.000 probanden weltweit
geimpft sind natürlich im augenblick
sehr schnell entwickelt worden
aber wir haben hier ja eine sehr große
gruppe die geimpft wurde und es taten
keine wesentlichen schwerwiegende
nebenwirkungen auf insofern macht das
durchaus hoffnung die eu hat bereits
mehrere hundert millionen dosen
vorbestellt hohe erwartungen also auch
bei der bundesregierung das war ja bis
hierhin unsicher ob es überhaupt einen
impfstoff geben kann
der tatsächlich wirkt der tatsächliche
infektionsgeschehen reduzierten
infektionen vermeiden hilft
und danach sieht es stand heute aus und
das
zu ermutigen 1,4 milliarden dosen will
bei montech bis ende nächsten jahres
herstellen und hofft nun auf eine
schnelle zulassung
ob das dieses jahr erfolgt dass das
werde ich nicht ausschließen dass kann
sagen dass es dieses jahr erfolgen kann
es kann aber auch sein dass es anfang
nächsten jahres die ergebnisse von heute
könnten diesen prozess beschleunigen
je näher ein impfstoff rückt desto
dringlicher wird die frage wer bekommt
ihm zuerst klar sei risikogruppen
müssten vorrang haben das sagen die
wissenschaftlichen berater der
bundesregierung
sie sagen genauso klar die impf spritze
gegen korona ist freiwillig mehr dazu
jetzt von frankenwald und betten in
berliner messehallen für corona
patienten bisher nicht benutzt zum glück
hier könnte nun bald im zentrum
entstehen eines von dutzenden in
deutschland ein serum ist in sicht nur
wer bekommt die impfung zuerst
wissenschaftler wollen prioritäten
setzen
priorisierung deshalb weil es nicht von
anfang an möglich sein wird alle in
villingen in unserer bevölkerung mit
einem stoff wirklich zu verfolgen zu
versorgen
zuerst sollen risikogruppen geimpft
werden also ältere oder patienten mit
vorerkrankungen zweites medizinisches
und pflegepersonal dann menschen in
besonders relevanten funktionen etwa
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
gesundheitsämter polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden feuerwehr
lehrerinnen und lehrer erzieherinnen und
erzieher und so weiter zugleich hat das
corona kabinett eine nationale
impfstrategie entwickelt hier steht eine
priorisierung nach berufsgruppen im
vordergrund ein daten portal nach alter
geschlecht und wohnort könnte mögliche
risiko gruppen ermitteln allerdings ohne
namen cupid impfungen sind danach
generell freiwillig und kostenlos
wir wissen dass wir um eine ausreichende
immunität in der bevölkerung zu
erreichen
etwa 70 prozent der menschen dass 70
prozent der menschen mitmachen müssen
sich impfen lassen
fürs impfen gilt also ganz ähnlich wie
beim infektionsschutz
es kommt auf alle an die suche nach
einem impfstoff ist auch thema bei heute
live um 20 uhr auf heute de einen
überblick über den forschungsstand
finden sie auch jederzeit in unserer zdf
heute app und jetzt der blick auf die
korona zahlen in deutschland im schnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
bei uns täglich 19 1750 menschen neu
angesteckt etwas mehr als am vortag
die deutschen krankenhäuser melden heute
3005 corona intensivpatienten
das sind erstmals mehr als im frühjahr
da lag der höchstwert bei 2.850 noch
drastischer ist die krone entwicklung
bei unseren nachbarn in der schweiz
dort ist die zahl der neuinfektionen
sprunghaft angestiegen von 100.000
einwohnern haben sich innerhalb von
sieben tagen sechs 172,4 infiziert im
vergleich dazu deutschland da sind es
166 3 diese entwicklung führt in der
schweiz zu einer ethischen triage
diskussion
das heißt zu der frage wer bekommt im
zweifelsfall ein intensiv bett und wer
nicht andreas linke berichtet vor allem
in der westschweiz in den kantonen genf
waadt und wallis hat sich die lage in
den krankenhäusern zugespitzt aber sie
sagen noch sei die situation im griff
wir verteilen auch patienten gleichmäßig
in andere krankenhäuser um die qualität
der pflege zu gewährleisten und in der
deutschschweiz gibt es noch genügend
freie plätze
doch was wenn intensivbetten in den
krankenhäusern noch knapper werden über
85-jährigen sollte man sie notfalls
verweigern so lautete die umstrittene
empfehlung der schweizerischen akademie
der medizinischen wissenschaften
pflegeheimbewohner elisabeth ranch und
hans rudi hartmann wären betroffen
ich würde eigentlich intensiv behandelt
werden wollen wenn ich es nötig hätte
vorausgesetzt ich hätte die chance zu
überleben
ich ging nicht mehr ins spital ich würde
hier bleiben wir werden hier gut
gepflegt und gut aufgehoben
die akademie hat reagiert die fragliche
empfehlung überarbeitet die strikte
altersgrenze 85 gilt nun nicht mehr
der allgemeinzustand soll weiteres
kriterium bleiben in der schweiz hoffen
sie aber solche entscheidungen weiterhin
nicht treffen zu müssen
die usa sind nach wie vor das am
stärksten von corona betroffene land mit
jetzt fast zehn millionen infizierten
der künftige präsident joe biden hat
experten zusammengetrommelt um direkt
bei seinem amtsantritt im januar mit
einer neuen strategie gegen die pandemie
loslegen zu können
doch der amtierende präsident donald
trump verweigert jegliche zusammenarbeit
und will partout nicht aufgeben
matti wissen wenn donald trump vom
golfen zurückkehrt sieht er durch die
scheibe jubelnde anhänger wie sie
weigert er sich die niederlage
anzuerkennen zumindest bis sich zeigt ob
die klagen vor gericht erfolgreich sind
für den designierten präsidenten nicht
einfach weil die krisen des landes
schnelles handeln erfordern joe biden
und seine neue corona taskforce besetzt
mit top wissenschaftler
wir wollen schnell test fast überall
verfügbar machen ein chor von kontakte
ermittlern schaffen um die ansteckungen
einzudämmen
während dann impfstoffe zuerst an die
verteilt werden die am meisten gefährdet
sind
wir müssen den streit beenden und die
stärke und vitalität unserer nation
verteidigen
normalerweise hätte beiden stars jetzt
schon zugang ins gesundheitsministerium
und andere regierungsbehörden um über
eine schnelle produktion und verteilung
möglicher impfstoffe zu sprechen
übergaben finde ja oft zwischen
erbitterten gegnern stadt nach einem
harten wahlkampf aber ich hoffe dass
trump in einigen tagen zur besinnung
kommt denn es geht hier nicht um seine
politischen interessen sondern um
die interessen der nation but the
nation's interesse von obama zu trump
gab es solch eine reibungslose übergabe
aber jetzt verweigert die trump
administration ihre unterstützung in
arizona und anderswo warten tram fans
auf ein signal ihres präsidenten trampel
möglicherweise im ganzen land
kundgebungen veranstalten und sein
archiv vom wahlbetrug verbreiten bisher
fehlt dafür jeder beweis aber der
präsident der seit tagen nur pendelt
zwischen golfplatz und weißem haus will
davon offenbar nichts wissen eine
wichtige frage ist ob und wie lange die
republikaner an donald trump festhalten
seine anhänger jedenfalls braucht die
partei auch weiterhin schon bald
besonders in georgia dort wird im januar
per stichwahl über gleich zwei senatoren
posten entschieden gewinnen ihre
kandidaten könnten die republikaner joe
biden mit einer senatsmehrheit in
washington
viele politische steine in den weg legen
peter jäger über trump und die
republikaner ein präsident der sich
sperrt das weiße haus zu verlassen
und der um die loyalität der eigenen
partei fürchten muss zumindest auf den
ersten blick immer mehr leute in meiner
partei akzeptieren das ergebnis und
einige haben dem wahlsieger auch schon
gratuliert senator midway lobt joe biden
bewundert wänden charakter gouverneur
john kasich spricht von beiden als einen
präsidenten für das ganze land ohnehin
parteiinterne trank kritiker großes
schweigen dagegen bei denen die die
offizielle parteilinie vorgeben mitch
mcconnell etwa der mächtige
mehrheitsführer im senat
denn trotz niederlage hat schon für die
republikaner wichtige wählergruppen
hinzugewonnen auch frauen auch latinos
der jump ismus ist weiterhin
mehrheitsfähig gemacht die trump über
seine basis hat über die die wegen
globalisierung demografischer
entwicklung oder anderen frustriert sind
ist einmalig ich denke diese starke band
ist ein bisschen gefährlich
die partei kämpft um die senats mehr
es hängt an ihren beiden kandidaten in
georgia stichwahl ist im januar tram
schwerer werden gebraucht und so die
legende vom wahlbetrug aufrechterhalten
hat nicht verloren geben sie nicht auf
herr präsident kämpfen sie haut
parteiprominenz spielt wohl mit dem
gedanken trump in vier jahren noch
einmal antreten zu lassen
der hat eine welle losgetreten die die
partei offenbar weiter reiten will schon
am samstag hatte die bundeskanzlerin joe
biden und kamelle harris schriftlich zu
ihrem wahlsieg gratuliert heute tat
angela merkel ist noch mal mündlich
sie betonte die bedeutung der
zusammenarbeit von europa und den usa
sie bekannte sich zu einer stärkeren
eigenverantwortung der europäer und sie
lobte die beiden zur beiden bringt die
erfahrung aus jahrzehnten in der innen-
wie in der außenpolitik mit er kennt
deutschland und europa gut ich erinnere
mich gerne an gute begegnungen und
gespräche mit ihm
amerika ist und bleibt unser wichtigster
verbündeter aber es erwartet von uns und
zurecht stärkere eigene anstrengung um
für unsere sicherheit zu sorgen und für
unsere überzeugungen in der welt
einzutreten
theo koll in berlin beginnt jetzt eine
neue ära deutsch amerikanische
freundschaft ja ich glaube man kann
sagen davon ist auszugehen und auch der
begriff freundschaft dürfte auf deutsch
amerikanischer regierungsebene erstmals
wieder angemessen sein beim jump ismus
rangierten wir ja nicht selten in einer
reihe mit iran oder china
aber ich glaube es wäre selbsttäuschung
zu erwarten dass wird joe biden alles
wieder so wird wie früher die usa ihre
interessen und politischen koordinaten
haben sich ja verändert in der rivalität
mit china beispielsweise dürfte
washington künftig mehr kritisches
bekenntnis von berlin erwarten auch wenn
das deutschen wirtschaftsinteressen
zuwiderläuft und die usa warten dass die
berliner verbündete mehr militärische
verantwortung und damit höhere
verteidigungsausgaben übernehmen und wie
die kanzlerin heute meinte sie erwarten
es zu recht also es wird eine neue ära
freundlicher im ton gemeinsamer in den
werten aber bleibend unterschiedlich bei
wichtigen interessen
die einschätzung von theo koll aus
berlin vielen dank für kopfschütteln und
unverständnis sorgt immer noch das was
am samstag in leipzig ab lief dort war
eine demonstration der querdenker gegen
korona maßnahmen aus dem ruder gelaufen
massiv kritisiert wird die justiz weil
sie erlaubt hat dass sich tausende in
leipzig zentrum versammeln gegen den
willen der stadt aber fragen gibt es
auch an die polizei hat sie genug um
ausschreitungen und übergriffe gegenüber
journalisten zu verhindern
thomas bärsch berichtet die bilder aus
leipzig vom samstag halle nach am
nachmittag tausende demonstranten auf
engem raum oft ohne abstand und maske
und abends ausschreitungen einzelner mit
angriffen auf polizei- und reporter das
oberverwaltungsgericht bautzen hatte die
querdenken demo am nachmittag genehmigt
und kopfschütteln ausgelöst
alle menschen sind angehalten abstand zu
halten und hier sagt ein gericht es ist
völlig in ordnung 16.000 menschen auf
einem kleinen platz quasi zusammen zu
verchen das ist schwer zu erklären dass
es schwer zu vermitteln mit 16.000
teilnehmern hatten die richter auf dem
augustusplatz zwischen oper und
gewandhaus gerechnet und dabei offenbar
nicht bedacht dass blumenrabatten
parkhäuser straßenbahn häuschen oder ein
brunnen die fläche stark begrenzten hier
war gedränge programmiert offenbar hatte
die polizei auch die masken pflicht
nicht durchgesetzt ebenso wenig wie die
auflösung der versammlung am ende beides
sorgte für kritik doch polizisten sehen
sich zu unrecht am pranger
hätten wir die wasserwerfer einsetzen
müssen die erste reihe wegblasen müssen
hat mit den wasserwerfern wenn wir dort
familien haben wenn wir kinder dabei
haben wenn wir frauen da war ja man so
weiter und so fort muss der
polizeiführer schon ganz genau überlegen
was er macht oder was das leichtere
mittel ist leipzig steht auch für die
frage wie der versammlungsfreiheit in
zukunft auch in corona zeiten geltung
verschafft werden kann
meinungen müssen öffentlich vertreten
werden können kritik soll und muss in
einer demo in einer demokratie auch
immer möglich sein
in leipzig wurde nun die
versammlungsfreiheit zum teil gezielt
ausgenutzt
die aufarbeitung läuft noch in dieser
woche will das ovg in bautzen erklären
warum es die demo in dieser form
nämlich hat der neunter november das ist
der tag des mauerfalls wegen der korona
pandemie gab es heute keine zentrale
gedenkveranstaltung in einer gemeinsamen
aktion steckten vertreter der stiftung
berliner mauer und der
versöhnungsgemeinde rosen in die
mauerreste
sie entzündeten kerzen am ehemaligen
todesstreifen an der bernauer straße um
an die opfer zu erinnern
viele verbinden mit dem 9 november auch
die pogromnacht 1938
damals hatten die nationalsozialisten in
ganz deutschland synagogen angezündet
geschäfte zerstört und jüdische bürger
ermordet
die stadt oranienburg und die
gedenkstätte sachsenhausen erinnerten an
die opfer der pogromnacht in personal kz
sachsenhausen waren mehr als 6300 juden
deportiert worden
sexueller missbrauch nach der
katholischen kämpft auch die
evangelische kirche mit der frage der
aufarbeitung die verantwortlichen in der
ekd sehen sich auf einem guten weg und
verweisen auf neue grundlegende
strukturen und instrumente vertreter der
betroffenen sehen das anders es sei kaum
etwas geschehen und opfer zu wenig
einbezogen worden
als zimmermann von seefahrt berichtet er
ist eines von fast 900 bekannten opfern
sexualisierter gewalt in der
evangelischen kirche dethleffs an das
enttäuschung über den prozess der
aufarbeitung ist groß und entsprechend
scharf die kritik der betroffenen die
jetzt druck machen wollen
zehn jahre nach beginn des sogenannten
missbrauchsskandals ist für die
evangelische kirche noch immer nicht
klar dass immer dort wurden raum der
kirche sexualisierte gewalt von
mitarbeitenden der kirchen statt
gefunden hat selbstverständlich
institutionelles versagen fest steht
schlicht weil es passiert ist die gewalt
stattgefunden hat
die kirche selbst die heute ihre digital
abgehaltene jahres synode beendete weist
den vorwurf zurück will im gegenteil
jetzt mit einer studie dieses dunkle
kapitel ihrer eigenen vergangenheit noch
einmal aufarbeiten
sicher ist dass seit 2012 schon an an
erkennungsleistung individuelle art 74
millionen
bei einer gesamtzahl von fällen sage ich
jetzt mal 880 geflossen ist das heißt
wir haben uns befasst wir setzen uns
auseinander als eine institution die
versagt hat echte
entschädigungszahlungen sind allerdings
noch nicht geflossen das so die
betroffenen sei aber dringend geboten da
viele von ihnen zu den älteren gehören
und ich kann mittlerweile zu der
überzeugung dass es ohne den staat nicht
geht und ohne externe unabhängige
strukturen kirchen müssen in einer
rechenschaftspflicht gezwungen werden
die evangelische kirche deutschlands
verweist auch darauf dass der
aufarbeitungsprozess noch längst nicht
abgeschlossen ist
und soeben wird gemeldet der noch
amtierende us präsident donald trump hat
verteidigungsminister mag es bei
entlassen er ersetzte ihn durch den anti
terror chef christopher müller in der
karibik und in mittelamerika hat der
tropensturm meter schon heftig gewütet
etwa 200 menschen sind bereits ums leben
gekommen jetzt ist der sturm auch im us
bundesstaat florida auf land getroffen
die behörden warnen vor
lebensgefährlichen überflutungen zuvor
hatte er in mehreren ländern schwere
zerstörungen angerichtet
etwa durch erdrutsche wie hier in
guatemala und jetzt sind ihre norbert er
und zur fußball nationalmannschaft die
in den nächsten acht tagen richtig
gefordert ist mittwoch
freundschaftsspiel gegen tschechien
danach die beiden letzten nations in die
gruppenspiele gegen die ukraine und
spanien
beim testspiel übermorgen in leipzig
wird bundestrainer läuft deshalb auf
einige stammspieler verzichten
statt groß und gabri gibt es erstmal max
und barcoo der seit samstag am knie
verletzte josua kimmig fehlt sowieso tut
natürlich weh dass er heute nicht da ist
aber ist trotzdem gut dass er nicht
allzu lange ausfällt und hoffentlich im
januar dann auch wieder voll
durchstarten kann
erst am samstag gegen die ukraine soll
die beste elf wieder glänzen die kritik
nach zuletzt sieben gegentoren in drei
spielen ist dem dfb zu düster geraten
dann muss ich sagen tut es mir
eigentlich sehr weh wie gerade so mit
den jungen spielern umgegangen wird und
wie eigentlich möchte ich mal sagen wir
sind ein bisschen immer so eine dunkle
wolke über die nationalmannschaft
geschoben wird
unter verschärften hygienebestimmungen
wird das team die länderspiele
bestreiten bis zur rückreise aus spanien
nächste woche gestern abend das eins zu
eins zwischen englands meister liverpool
und vize-meister manchester city die
beiden trainer klopp und guardiola im
ärger vereint aber nicht wegen des
spiels sondern wegen des zu großen
termindrucks für die spieler zu wenig
erholung immer noch drei statt fünf
auswechslungen wie in der bundesliga
dennoch ist das ein temporeiches spiel
in dem dieses foul an sah die manöver
pool die chance zur frühen führung
bringt mohammed salon mit dem 1 0 in der
13 minute manchester citys antwort in
der 31 minute gabriel jesus schaltet am
schnellsten und trifft zum ausgleich und
so bleibt es trotz vieler chancen
ich war begeistert von der energie
leistung beider teams es war ein wahrer
kampf ein
liverpools rettet das 1 1-unentschieden
verliert aber die tabellenspitze
und zwar in bester city liverpool jetzt
dritter
das wetter bietet zumindest ab und an
lichtblicke mal sonne oft wolken und
nebel und dabei entweder unangenehm kalt
oder überraschend mild einzelheiten
gleich von katja honnefer christian
sievers spricht im heute journal mit
gesundheitsminister sparen um fünf vor
halb elf wir danken für ihr interesse
und wünschen ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren einige von
ihnen hatten heute strahlenden
sonnenschein und andere saßen im dicken
nebel und diese nebelfelder lösen sich
zum teil gar nicht auf wie hier an der
donau bis hinauf richtung franken und
auch am bodensee blieb es lange sehr
nämlich in den osten gab es dichte
wolken und im westen brachten diese
wolken auch ein kleines bisschen regen
mit und so ähnlich geht es in den
nächsten tagen auch weiter jetzt in der
nacht bildet sich erst mal wieder zum
teil dicker nebel und die temperaturen
sinken entlang des rheins auf 9 bis 6
grad sonst wird es deutlich kühler mit
+3 bis -2 grad da droht also überall
wieder boden pfosten das könnte auch
glatt seien auf den straßen
morgen sind die temperaturen kraft
unterschiedlich wenn sich der nebel
nicht auflöst sind schon vier grad eher
hoch gegriffen sonst werden es sechs bis
zehn grad am rhein geht auf 13 bis 16
grad drauf in norddeutschland haben sie
morgen kaum eine chance auf die sonne
das sieht im harz anders aus oberhalb
der hochnebel obergrenze die liegt bei
67 800 meter haben sie strahlenden
sonnenschein
das gilt auch für das erzgebirge für die
eifel und sehr dichte nebelfelder gibt's
auch wieder an der donau
ganz ähnlich geht am mittwoch weiter
donnerstag und freitag kommt im westen
etwas bewegung ins wetter mit etwas
regen und hier wünsche ich ihnen noch
einen schönen abend